let's go a wrap it up a day
now shanks on player1 only have the
vegeto how did I forget the Vegeta on
point in the cell back another and go
things at the end Padre shakes versus
subatomic sabers here we go
both players starting up the back - you
can see Larson be shown the wood and air
live from shanks yeah that's some rain
in the air your looks gonna be a hundred
seventeen assists gets the head hit with
the light there oh yeah
not trying to deal with this but it's
not going to matter
that's bargaining it's not gonna get you
out of the corner here and it is a level
one sparking yeah showed up the super -
it was hit him with the empty low the
spam load from Andrew 18 so quick going
right into that level 3 to knock to be
able to spark out of it's gonna get some
mix off and there wasn't going to be
goes for 17 assists on the ground jump
hexa did not MIT there
because last summer summer savers all
look little for half a second gets
snatched away to being smashed once
again I don't know she snatched my heart
[Music]
still very potent character in the hands
of shames it's all defense all they try
to sleep a little bit too quickly
making quick work here in the corner and
going into the level three
another shanks walk here trying to
miscarry her alive take the momentum
back for himself discipline because of
that
they'll own the meter penalty still
ticked and all he's gonna need and have
to write it out to be done to bars if
necessary which it won't be is down
Android 18 but shame that the beautiful
thing about the team is though hip bones
just scribbled up yet though so you
won't have to try and speak one of those
in here soon to really use old pump oh
yeah talk to the hand 5s
looking to probably try and get them in
the corner to puppy yeah hi this is a
piece of hitboxes and crouched on their
phone besides that's pretty good so the
top it with a nice conversion right
there
[Music]
forget Goku
that was sick this goes with the regular
jumping you saw he showed him to jump
age at the very last second just a fool
with the animation that that like pulled
me for a second where some atomic right
there was a perfect attack convertible
Shane she's trying to recover from this
while it's buggy so actually it's it was
a super - very well gosh that's holding
the badge did the optimal stuff level
three from Quahog
I still don't think he's leveled up so
for the fastball with the rock tagging
to go tanks here yeah those raw fastball
get moving the gas need it to tag out
this character the fake scream so this
on the Savior's love things know buy
some time and get that Seles is back as
well hunger food a bit too early there
for the dragon runs of just shanks gonna
be able to built the two bars here he's
gonna need the so extension to kill no
and he's not gonna have it just set up
shop
both off he's level one to clear the
screen and the level of very smart snap
back to Super Saiyan Goku the last
second and then it give is catching
chase trying to press appliance
some atomic to Paris to one's chains is
leveled up punks great taxpayer from
shanks as well we going in with the
heavy legs those prices of the dragon
rocks hits that pin secures it yeah a
lot of times players like to reflect
definitely age later Gohan and he gets
clipped by it again that's a huge damage
starter he's gonna give the smash
knockdown as well thank you buffs that
is how you get erased as soon as you get
hit by those heavy legs your life flash
before your eyes oh yeah so what's all
it started with the medium as well can
be able to smash back into the corner
here yeah man the level one will do it
subatomic what all over shakes you know
run up and do like a 2m or something yes
something cuz they're getting the 299
second round they both started with a
back - fries so I'm sure he was reading
another back - but
[Music]
a little bit longer this paint here
it definitely hurt me for sure for you
jump like falling hell and now he's
gonna snap him out lost that go tanks oh
man 70 paid off the cameraman and he's
still blocked debated it out and
punished perfectly yeah trying to fall
with that light being clip four is gonna
get the go takes out here yeah
I believe in the sparking right here I
think this was the right choice made
gotta save 18 this side
great defense low of subatomic savers
right now
wow what a slight bow but subatomic you
saw shakes put the 17 assists counter on
there right this business rock actor
Coleman who says instead some pop
according the attempt of shanks Oh folks
from in the mouth
yeah that's a lay there
[Music]
it's not like yeah those white gloves
would be covered in blood that those are
the dishwashing gloves be fair can i
majin buu they would be that's my father
box of glue
the big dishwasher closed
Oh Padre it's opened up here by go tanks
there are three bars on deck about
before yeah some atomic what could give
you those picky screams he's so good at
conditioning his opponent to try to run
cleansing yet he's obnoxiously long
block streams and because of that he
gets away with stuff like the fake
scream and some atomic savers now a
three to one on shanks another favorite
here to go deep in the tournament we're
gonna take it to the corner with the
legs
Oh dragon roars haven't bad again
sliding knock down into the final
kamehameha
and what if it gonna be a dirt goes
right into the to end there I think
it's with a sword not going to be not
here to kill but things are not looking
good for shapes this keeps it nice and
simple summer time it savers takes it to
over one of the favorites of the
tournament yeah making a real real run
here at this tournament here